داخل مستشفى الشهيد ابوو يوسف النجار هنا
في مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه تصل عشرات
الاصابات من منطقه المواص الساحليه غربيه
خانيونس بعدما تعذرت سيارات الاسعاف
الوصول الى هذه المناطق وايضا نقل الشهداء
واجلاء المصابين الى مشافي خان يونس بفعل
حصار المنطقه الغربيه من قبل الدبابات
الاسريه الان كما تشاهدون هنا امامكم تصل
الاصابات تباعا من مختلف الفئات العمريه
بصعوبه بالغه وكبيره جدا تصل الاصابات هنا
الى هذا المكان والى ساحه هذا المستشفى
كما يشاهدون معظم الاصابات من الواضح انها
خطره وبقيت تنزف في الطرقات وفي الاحياء
وبانتظار وصول سيارات الاسعاف لتحويل هذه
الاصابه ايضا الى مشافي مدينه خانيونس
جنوبي قطاع غزه وبطبيعه الحال هذا يعكس
حجم نيران القوات الاسرائيل التي حاصرت
المناطق الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس هنا هنا
اصابه اخرى ايضا في ساحه غرفه العنايه
المركزه في قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ في
مستشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار يجري تحويل
هذه الاصابه الى المشفى الاوروبي في
خانيونس ونقلها من قبل الطواقم الطبيه بعد
تقديم الاسعافات الاوليه الى هذه الطفله
التي وصلت عبر مركبات الاسعاف قبل لحظات
من الان هنا الى هذا المشفى هنا ايضا
ينتشر المدنيين عدد من الشهداء الذين
وصلوا عبر مركبات اسعاف بعد اما نقلوا الى
منطقه قريبه من مدينه رفح من مواسم مدينه
خانيونس جنوب قط غزه الله اكبر شهيد اخر
شهيد اخر
كانوا على البحر في خيم قاعدين مش اليهود
بيقولوا روحوا على البحر روحوا في المواصي
كانوا في البحر بعتوا لهم قذائف من
المدفعيه وحرقهم صوبوا هيوم وماتوا من خان
يونس قالوا بلوك 55 والبلوكات اللي عدوهم
اليهود وطلعوا منهم نازحين ويهم ماتوا
حسبي الله عليهم ان شاء الله الله ينتقم
منهم يا رب ينتقم منك يا نتنياهو حصر على
اولادك يا رب اذا هي منطقه المواص
الساحليه غربيه خان يونس ورفح التي لا
طالما قالت اسرائيل بانها منطقه امنه لكن
عمليات القتل التي نراها والاصابات في
صفوف هؤلاء النازحين تبدد المزاعم
الاسرائيليه بانها منطقه امنه هاني الشاعر
لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح